Speaker 1: All right, let's hear from a few
more of you in the audience. We take calls
these days via discord. You can find The David
Pakman Show discord at David Pakman dotcom slash
discord. Let's go next to Ashley from
Florida. Ashley, you were on the air.
Speaker 4: Hi, David, I'm a big fan of yours. I
listen to you all the time. Thank you. Thanks for
taking my call. Pleasure. I am in Florida
and right now what we're dealing with are
no mosques and schools. We have people fighting
against CRT. And I recently went to one of our
school board meetings trying to advocate
for mosques and schools. There is no the
state has not taken funding or education for
virtual options from the federal government. So
I feel really out of luck with my kids.
I'm just wondering, with the recent events,
with the boys being at the meetings in California
yesterday, will not the meetings but the
Speaker 1: at the Newsome rally?
Speaker 4: Yeah, yeah. They're also here
in our schools and our in our board meetings.
Speaker 1: And so let me let me see if I can
understand that actually these are parents who
are also proud boys or these are just random,
proud boys going to the school board
meetings to complain about masks
Speaker 4: their parents that are proud boys.
Speaker 1: Oh, wow. There are parents that are
proud boys in the school district. Yes, and are
they making a big commotion at the meetings?
Speaker 4: No, there were a lot of police, that's
the one we were at, which I know it seems like
sometimes are one in the same, but because I
think of the extra police presence they had,
there wasn't a fight. But the county north
of me and Lee, they had a fight recently.
You did a story on them? Yeah.
Speaker 1: Listen, I don't know,
I'm going to be really honest, I was just talking
to friends who have kids right now recently, and
I was saying if throughout this pandemic I had had
children and had to figure out daycare, schooling,
they can't be vaccinated. Some places don't want
them to wear masks. I don't know what I would have
done. It seems impossibly difficult, like I just
can't even imagine it's one of the worst aspects
of this pandemic. Does it occur to you to pull the
kids from school? Is that even possible? Not that
I'm recommending, not that I'm recommending.
Speaker 4: Yeah, I have pulled from school,
but there's some parents who, even
if they wanted to, they can't because
there's no funding. The state refused federal
funding for virtual options, so they didn't really
give parents a choice on the right end of things.
Speaker 1: Right. And some people are saying I'm
going to homeschool, but that's No. One, arguably
not so good socially for the kids and no to a lot
of parents work. So they can't be homeschooling.
Speaker 4: Right. And I think everybody deserves
to be able to have a public education and be safe.
Speaker 1: Absolutely. Yeah, no, I can't I can't
even imagine. It's I mean, what what are what's
the hope? Just that we eventually get past the
pandemic. I mean, is there really any solution
while the pandemic is going on? It seems like it's
becoming a lost cause in some of these counties.
Speaker 4: I know that's why I was calling you.
Speaker 2: Yeah, let's see if you had any answers.
Speaker 1: Do you have it? I'm like, are you
is there any action you're thinking
of taking? Let me put it that way.
Speaker 4: Yeah, we have we're trying to organize,
but I think we're really outnumbered here.
It's difficult.
Speaker 1: Yeah, yeah.
Well, listen, Ashleigh, I wish I had specific
advice for you. I don't because it's a tough
situation, but I were with you and keep
us posted about what goes on down there.
Speaker 2: OK, thanks, David.
Speaker 1: All right. Thanks,
Ashley. Ashley from Florida. Not a good
situation, guys. Not a good situation
at all. Let's speak next to Emily, Emily,
you are on the air. And Emily disappeared